[Music]
in asking for too much news oh joy says
that submitted by concrete rose a couple
received regret checker what that's a to
pop rather their Oh a couple received
backlash after asking neighbors to do
their chores after they have a baby just
once or like Villa can you permanently
wash our floors from now on so this all
started on this website called Neil
train oh cool giving website and so
they're asking so most people ask for
meal donations out of need but this man
in Philadelphia uh he was asking for a
lot just because they're about to have
their first child so he also kind of put
this on his next door app like for his
neighbors to see and so a neighbor of
his who came across this tweeted it out
and people are like what the [ __ ] I
could date we asked him for so much this
is what it looks like on the meal train
it says meal train for Jim and Alex and
baby then here's a photo of them fan
paths as a father-to-be I'm teetering on
offensive emotions on one side is joy
and excitement of course but on the
other side is a great deal of fear one
of the things I'm most afraid of is not
getting a great deal of sleep and as a
result not being in the best frame of
mind to offer my wife the support she
needs to recover from the child birthing
process that's why I'm putting together
this meal train or mental health check
in train or do you need any help today
train a meal would be awesome if you
feel comfortable reaching out before you
feel sorry before you arrive to see if
we might need anything else that'd be
even more awesome neither of us are
particularly extroverted or easy with
direct asks for assistance but having
some postpartum support prearranged will
serve our comfort levels as we move into
the new phase of our existence lot of
what so then to users like make it
comfortable wait he doesn't have family
huh so he did say originally he created
this for family and friends
you just kind of put it out there just
be like if strangers want to help I
wouldn't want strangers in my house so
he wouldn't either so he also put and
hit the like special instructions
section that he if they he'll be putting
this like cooler on the side gate of
their home so people could just come in
and like put a meal in the cooler but it
sounds all like but if they poison him
so it's like can you come and do all
this yard work take out the trash do all
this stuff outside well so then that
that is kind of part of it too like if
you don't want to give us meals how
about you walk the dog vacuum our house
do the dishes even though no one owes
him anything exactly so then like one of
the tweets from the neighbor he says try
not to be negative I figured maybe it's
like if you can't make a lasagna and or
if you make a lasagna and make too much
we would accept it that would be very
reasonable inside a totally unreasonable
ask and then in all caps but there were
30 plus specific meals with recipes oh
my god Oh what yeah it feels weird for
me to ask for it
hand out like that that's the definition
of beggars can't be choosers yeah right
that's the thing and if I ask for help
for sure I'm already ready to return a
later on I know I need help I'll return
the favor later nobody should have told
this guy doesn't hurt to ask
I know hurts a lot man and another
person was like they're having a baby
not both dying of cancer thank you my
god cuz why does he think that what he's
going through is so special and unique
to him like like everyone has a [ __ ]
baby hey nobody told you to have a kid
yeah that's if you don't want the
pressures of that that don't have a kid
that's the usually the thing that people
go through the struggle that's been tied
alas [ __ ] it is like this this this
wouldn't be that crazy if he was sending
it to people he has rapport with yeah
that's different right but now he's just
sending it to strangers and putting it
out to the universe like someone's gonna
be like for some wild reason I feel so
responsible for your well-being thank
you
I bet you there people out there that
are like you know what this is my
calling to help out these people and
they'll are [ __ ] crazy but it
like that right off the bat you know
they're gonna be even more demanding if
you give them an inch they're gonna take
a mile and even if I had rapport with
somebody you like yeah like you know I
don't have time to cook do you mind like
like I wanna like a home-cooked meal you
might of course I would but then if it
comes with by the way here's the recipe
and this how I want you to be well you
can [ __ ] start to death and I hope
your kid falls down some stairs yeah
because that turns around like oh I want
to slap you now yeah I came I came
bearing gifts but not want to smack you
in the face they're the type of people
like to sweep their floors and they're
like you missed a spot over there
they're that type of people yeah yeah so
then obviously this guy and this was
just viral and add some more more to
this so than they were saying too that
they discovered that the same couple
they previously when they first got
pregnant they started a podcast called
not a parenting podcast and every week
they would talk for an hour about their
pregnancy and they're just saying like
oh yeah we we know that a lot of people
go through this but it hasn't happened
to us and so we're gonna talk about it
kind of thing so then in one of the
episodes they started talking about
about this like this whole idea of
having a meal train or like having me
like asking neighbors to help in and
that they should have some postpartum
support that's what family is supposed
to do that but like let's say cuz
because I have heard of this thing where
like you get your neighborhood like if
you're close with your neighbors again
the rapport thing yeah there poor thing
yeah then you ask like like you know new
parents that's the hardest thing for
them to do is to like cook meals luckily
now we have post mates but that's one of
the things that's like comment to gift
you know like they have a new baby then
you go and you like cook for them or you
offer those types of services um
what they're doing too is even more
[ __ ] up because there's no rapport and
they don't they're like well we're
actually pretty introverted so we're
just gonna leave a cooler out there so
it's like more engine you have to text
me if you're coming over that's weird
cuz if they were like okay you know what
like this is a trying time for us I like
but like you guys are more than welcome
to come in we can make a community out
of this like there
no they're not not being inclusive at
all it's more like just leave your
should give me free [ __ ] yeah but you
were talking about how people gift the
meal services they got gift cards to
food to a food service and they have
about six weeks worth of meal whoa from
just that oh [ __ ] and plus they're
adding all this and then they were also
gifted like an instant pot whatever cuz
they talked about their baby shower
gifts yeah oh so they're covered for and
then also sweet so like when the news
outlets dug up their podcast
they also found out that they were
asking to fund the podcast as what like
people that we're listening like oh yeah
so which one their podcast - I bet you
it works that's why they're doing it
yeah this no it actually did we don't
know how to ask for [ __ ] is that what's
what's the real problem yeah find my
podcast he was like he tweeted this
there it has only been one response and
it's been a positive now I have two
houses to egg so it says hey neighbor we
live across the street when it's the
crazy dog and a three year old who
certainly know how tough this time can
be and what a big transition it is so
count on us for support we'll be in
touch so then the guy that's tweeting is
like I'm gonna egg - well it's true I
had a friend who like she was like that
where she just felt like kind of entire
yeah entitled but like why wouldn't you
give me this like why wouldn't you and
so people would give her [ __ ] so like it
kind of like reinforced that belief that
like if I ask for it like why wouldn't
people give it to me she would she like
return the favor though if someone else
is asking that she goes Walt someone
help me someone L go no because it was
already it was always money related so
like it's cuz she can't afford it
because she doesn't have money well go
get a job no I can't get a job because I
don't like people and it's like well no
one likes cute there's some people who
work at the lab yeah this is like oh I'm
not skilled enough or I don't want to
work that long some people are very
spoiled the ones I hate is people that
send me there what does that call the
group were they fun what does it go
without me go fund me yeah they send me
their GoFundMe link like hey um we want
to go on vacation can you just
[ __ ] you this is a [ __ ] luxury
thought a necessity you piece of [ __ ]
there's a lot of a [ __ ] random
GoFundMe it's like hey like I had a hard
semester and I really want to go on this
trip to Mexico cool me too I would love
to go to Mexico - you [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] what about me that's
not fair yeah I mean like if they said
like yo I need some books so for
studying purpose of qualities they're
honest they could have said I need it
for books and you give them money and
they go to Mexico I want the comfort of
the lie okay it takes more it takes more
of creativity to come up with the [ __ ]
outlandish stories yeah I'd be a normal
person and pretend that you need it for
something serious and then use it for
whatever you want to do so then the dad
who are like the dad to be Santa Claus
yeah Santa Claus he he ended up saying
quote I apologize if I was taking the
wrong way and I'm frankly just very
surprised no he put it out the wrong way
yeah what are you talking about I took
it exactly the way he put it about and
disheartened by the responses if they
are not interested then they don't have
to check out that site or do anything
this is the world we live in what the
entitled world we live in maybe so he's
in the right and the people are wrong
yeah yeah he was thinking oh there's so
many haters in this world you know
everyone always thinks that [ __ ] oh
somebody just hey you're just hating on
me you're just jealous this will
literally put out like a piggy bank on
his porch and he's like hey I take euros
dollars no he's like I take only dollars
ya have to be 20s but I don't want those
big colobus is gonna have the grape
vines or ones they're too much like the
meal that he was putting to like they
put his favorite snacks they listed dry
roasted and salted almonds homemade
granola that homemade granola paleo
breakfast egg muffins with Finley flies
crimini mushrooms pork breakfast sausage
Oh
hope that you don't vaccinate your kids
that's what I hope kid be for the type
of people that gets a free sample from a
restaurant on Yelp and then [ __ ]
leaves a bad review and could they
didn't like it yeah cuz I because I know
the perspective that he's coming from me
what are you saying like if you well you
don't have to if you don't want to but
the difference is is that you're not
selling a service or good that's like a
market thing right the market will be
yeah yeah yeah yeah you're asking for
charity
because you're putting your position as
somebody who is so rundown and tired
that they can't do these things so
you're it doesn't apply you know
anything like you [ __ ] dumb [ __ ] oh
man I hope you can break your ankle so
bad that's all the kids fall hey [ __ ]
that kid - alright I'm just kidding god
bless your soul but [ __ ] your parents
yeah gonna create more spoiled children
yeah hopefully it gets like a pile of
balloon and it's blue lit like here eat
this Filipino delicacy
[Music]